cia officer mark polymeropoulos went to
moscow in 2017 for meetings with russian
intelligence officials
paula meropoulos never thought he'd come
back to the u.s with a career-ending
traumatic brain injury it's been four
years of a 24 7 headache which is you
know not only is it painful physically
but just from a mental health
perspective it's pretty it's pretty
debilitating so while i've gotten better
because the treatment i've received at
walter reed's national intrepid center
of excellence that's one of the world's
leading traumatic brain injury programs
i'm still not there yet so i'm still
suffering palomaropola says he woke up
in his hotel room dizzy ears ringing and
suffering a never-ending migraine
a year earlier diplomats at the u.s
embassy in havana reported similar
symptoms
at first the u.s government considered
the cases anomalies but five years later
at least 200 u.s government officials
and some of their relatives are
struggling to recover from unexplained
health incidents also known as havana
syndrome
the biden administration says these
cases have spurred it to find the cause
when you sit down with with our people
and hear
[Applause]
what's happened to them
how they've been affected
it's very very powerful
and it only reinforces
in me
the absolute conviction that we need to
do everything possible
for our people to care for them
to protect them
to get to the bottom of what happened
the assumption the officials are being
attacked with weapons that use lasers or
microwaves instead of bullets similar to
what's being demonstrated here
the injuries have turned up in vienna in
bogota in guangzhou and in hanoi
just before vice president kamala
harris's visit in august
some speculate russia is behind the
attacks a charge the kremlin denies
still cia director bill burns recently
warned moscow there would be payback if
true
the trump administration also blamed
cuba expelling some of their diplomats
in 2017.
mark palmeropoulos and his lawyer
believe the government should tell the
public all it knows we don't know
what the intelligence community knows
truly about these
incidents
and if revealing certain information
would cause our country greater problems
but i'd like to think
that hopefully we are the victim
and solely the victim in this situation
and that we have something that we can
do in response
doctors say the cases resemble the
traumatic brain injuries u.s forces
suffered in ied attacks during the iraq
war
congress recently passed the havana act
to make sure the injured get the care
they need but it doesn't address the
growing unease some feel about serving
abroad
mark palamaropoulos says the cia has
stood by him in the past four years but
he wants the u.s to send a message these
attacks won't be tolerated they say this
is an act of war and so we're going to
have to respond appropriately so you
know i don't think this is just simple
sanctions um certainly you don't want to
start you know world war iii over this
but there's going to be have to have to
be some really tough measures taken
against our adversary you know if it's
russia this is this is serious business
now
a call to action to protect those who
thought they knew the risks that came
with their jobs
rosalind jordan al jazeera washington